come i tempi ci diamo noi è una persona
di successo
mi sono fatta la domanda venendo a
matera perché
ho pensato di salire su questo palco e
parlare di qualcosa che nessuno conosce
quindi mi sto confrontando con una
piattaforma sulla quale sono saliti
architetti matematici scrittori
giornalisti persone che insomma ci hanno
da dire qualcosa
e quindi
mi sono sentita veramente nonostante la
stazza mi sono sentita una manetta fra
giganti
e ha pensato ma come posso calcare lo
stesso palcoscenico di queste persone
così di talento no
poi mi sono resa conto che con loro
condivido la passione e l'amore per il
lavoro che faccio e l'entusiasmo che ci
mette ogni volta che mi confronto con o
cliente perciò ho detto ma sì ma in
fondo posso parlare anch'io alter ex
il flash che purtroppo è un argomento
che è poco noto
quindi chiaramente non vi potrò spiegare
questa disciplina in pochi minuti perché
è veramente molto complessa e affonda le
sue radici nella cina millenaria quindi
immaginate che alla base ci sono
filosofie importantissime
tra le quali la filosofia dei cinque
elementi lo yin e lo yang
l'almanacco lunare quindi nel francese
convergono a tante cose ma in realtà è
uno strumento di decodificazione delle
percezioni sottili immaginate di entrare
in uno spazio nuovo
entrare andati a trovare un amico che ha
cambiato casa entrare in una casa che
non conoscete
e quindi
avrete il dubbio di uno spazio nuovo vi
troverete a contatto con qualcosa di
nuovo ecco immaginate tentata in questa
casa qui e questa è la casa di un
intervento a milano
voi avrete
sentito qualcosa
magari si tratta di una sensazione
sgradevole perché quella casa non vi
piace oppure una sensazione gradevole
questa capacità di ascolto è
fondamentale è alla base della
sopravvivenza
quindi state facendo felice senza
saperlo
bravissimi
ora è chiaro che non è così semplice
però attraverso il lavoro con il feng
shui si può capire che cosa c'è che non
va nella nostra vita se ancora non ci
siamo resi conto da soli questa casa
appartiene ad un uomo sulla cinquantina
fiscalista di un'azienda petrolifera in
congo e era sicuramente una persona di
successo
se consideriamo che aveva la macchina
con autista
un attico con vista favolosa stipendio a
quattro zeri quindi sicuramente
stava male ma ha cominciato ad avere un
certo disagio e a non sopportare più la
vita che stava facendo
e
diciamo che ha cominciato anche ad
ammalarsi fisicamente
ascoltando questa sensazione non
positiva lui si è fermato e ha voluto
dare ascolto a quello che non andava
bene e allora ha smesso si è trasferita
a milano e si è fermato in attesa di
capire cosa fare poi tramite conoscenze
mi ha contattato e abbiamo lavorato
insieme
ora lui è stato bravo
fino a un certo punto ha lavorato da
solo a capire che c'era qualcosa che non
andava in casa sua io ho spostato il
tavolo vedete dalla foto il tavolo prima
era e mezzo alla stanza e adesso invece
appoggiato alla parete la colonna rossa
serve in quella in quella casa lì per
diciamo smuovere le situazioni e adesso
è uno chef vegano quindi chiaramente ha
fatto una rivoluzione totale no ha
cambiato completamente lavoro ha
cambiato vita
eppure oggi si sente soddisfatto e
felice e sano e quindi dal mio punto di
vista è una persona di successo
chiaramente
lui è stato bravo perché ha dato spazio
al movimento a quel moto interiore che
lo ha portato a vedere che dentro di se
c'era qualcosa che non funzionava
e in effetti il movimento è il cardine
del significato del di questi due
ideogrammi che sono il vento e l'acqua
che in natura più degli altri rendono
manifesta questa capacità di muoversi
delle cose è vero che si muovono anche i
ghiacciai anche le montagne la terra si
muove
però
il vento e l'acqua sono associati anche
alla vita
immaginate una terra senza vento il
polline non potrebbe spostarsi quindi
non ci sarebbero fiori nei frutti
immaginate una terra senza acqua
noi non potremmo esistere
quindi insieme al movimento c'è anche la
vita e che cosa succede quando noi
invece ci fermiamo per paura per per
ansia ci blocchiamo cirri giliano e alla
fine ci spezziamo quindi del face lei
il lavoro consiste soprattutto nel
rimettere in moto il flusso dell'energia
all'interno della casa ovviamente
ma soprattutto nella nostra vita quindi
facendo questo lavoro le persone
lavorano su se stesse ed iniziano un
percorso di consapevolezza
io ho scelto questa immagine qua
perché rappresenta
una strada
l'inizio di un percorso da una strada
nel bosco e mi ha ricordato vagamente
dante anche se ovviamente non possiamo
paragonarci al sommo poeta però mi ha
ricordato la fatica che si fa
nell'affrontare se stessi è un vero
lavoro
io ai miei clienti chiedo un atto di
coraggio sempre no un atto di fede no
perché non bisogna credere nel fashion
ma un atto di coraggio si perché le
persone devono abbandonare
l'attaccamento a quelle false sicurezze
e lasciarsi andare per scoprire i veri
talenti
i veri tesori che ci sono dentro di noi
e dare ascolto a quella voce che è solo
il movimento dell'anima che vuole
crescere vuole avanzare si vuole
espandere e quindi diciamo che nel
momento in cui qualcuno mi chiama e mi
chiede aiuto io non faccio altro che
farli da specchio e attraverso l'analisi
della sua carta natale con l'oroscopo
cinese e l'analisi della struttura della
casa
e rende evidente quali sono le cose che
dovrebbe aggiustare i temi su cui
lavorare perché magari non è stato
facile per questa persona rendersene
conto da sola e quindi per me la persona
di successo è questa
cioè quella che è stata capace di
ritornare a riscoprire non il bambino
interiore ma proprio il bambino il
bambino che che noi eravamo e che era
puro entusiasta gioioso capace di
affrontare la realtà senza paura perché
la paura è solo un'idea invece dobbiamo
avere fiducia nelle nostre capacità
andare avanti e niente è impossibile
per quelli che ci credono e per quelli
che si mettono in moto per gli altri
purtroppo vi lasciamo alle nostre spalle
grazie